and Chile's capital protests continue
against wealth inequality but many are
now turning their attention to state
prosecutors who intend to investigate 14
police officers accused of torturing
demonstrators there are more than 800
allegations of torture beatings and rape
committed by security forces over the
last three weeks of protests that's
added to widespread anger and calls for
president sebastián piñera
to resign he says guilty officers and
soldiers will be prosecuted we will
bring them to justice with the same
authority and protocol any excessive use
of force by police will also be
investigated by prosecutors and by the
courts this is what happens in a
democracy and under the rule of law the
President signed an order to increase
the country's minimum wage 16 percent to
about $470 a month
Congress will now decide if that measure
moves forward some Chileans are
skeptical the president is first and
foremost a Salesman he is an economic
speculator honestly I would not be
surprised if he's linked to companies
that are making money and profits from
this crisis what first began as protests
against an increase in public
transportation fees has now expanded to
the Capitals major highways with
complaints road tolls are too high
highway concessions have been in place
since 2006 companies have earned back
their investments eight times over yet
they continue to charge us you're taking
advantage of us and people aren't dead
on the streets protestors are talking
about extending their rallies to wealthy
districts that they have so far ignored
my view and human rights mission and
Amnesty International's say they're
investigating allegations of the
government committing abuses in Chile
the president insists his administration
has nothing to her
Katya lupus of the young al-jazeera